ya hablamos en detalle acerca del
concepto de desempleo en otros vídeos
ahora vamos a profundizar en qué
consiste la tasa de desempleo sólo como
un repaso la tasa de desempleo es el
porcentaje de personas en la fuerza
laboral que están buscando trabajo
activamente en esta gráfica de la
reserva federal de san luis tenemos la
tasa de desempleo indicada en color café
pueden ver cómo se mueve de acuerdo con
los ciclos económicos las áreas grises
muestran las recesiones y las áreas
blancas indican las expansiones observen
como la tasa de desempleo se dispara en
casi todas las recesiones o más bien en
todas las recesiones pero la gráfica
también muestra otros elementos esta
línea azul es la tasa natural de
desempleo y qué es eso
bueno como su nombre lo indica esta
línea azul es una aproximación de cuál
sería la tasa de desempleo si no
tuviéramos los periodos de expansión y
recesión que forman los ciclos
económicos en cierta forma podemos verlo
como una tasa de desempleo suavizada
entonces esto que está en color café es
la tasa de desempleo y la línea azul es
la tasa natural de desempleo que también
se conoce como
tn de la diferencia entre ambas es el
porcentaje de desempleo provocado por el
ciclo económico supongamos que estamos
en este punto donde tenemos una tasa
real de desempleo alta podemos ver esta
diferencia como la tasa de desempleo
menos la tasa natural de desempleo
este es el desempleo causado por el
ciclo económico y se conoce como
desempleo cíclico pueden observar que
durante las recesiones o poco después de
que termina una recesión cuando la tasa
de desempleo es muy alta el desempleo
cíclico o sea el desempleo provocado por
el ciclo económico va a ser positivo
pero cuando la economía realmente va
viento en popa incluso puede haber un
desempleo cíclico negativo como aquí
donde la tasa real de desempleo es menor
que la tasa natural de desempleo tal vez
las empresas tienen que contratar
personas que no están totalmente
calificadas para un trabajo se dice que
la economía está caliente y hay más
empleados de los que se necesitan en ese
momento determinado pero podemos
desglosar las cosas aún más vamos a
separar el concepto de tasa natural de
desempleo en dos componentes el
o estructural vamos a escribirlo con
color azul y el desempleo friccional no
tenemos datos precisos así que esta
información no es exacta pero supongamos
que la tasa de desempleo friccional es
todo esto entonces el desempleo
estructural sería el resto y juntos
suman la tasa natural de desempleo hasta
aquí todo bien pero que son el desempleo
estructural y el desempleo friccional
bueno el desempleo estructural es una
situación en la que se contabiliza a la
gente en la tasa de desempleo pero hay
una separación entre sus habilidades y
los requerimientos de los empresarios lo
cual hace que sea difícil encontrar
trabajo por ejemplo imaginemos que
estamos en la época en que los
automóviles empezaron a reemplazar a los
carruajes tirados por caballos
tal vez conducen uno de esos carruajes o
son buenos cuidando caballos pero ahora
la gente busca mecánico de coches
personas que sepan de automóviles o que
puedan ayudar a construir carreteras
para coches esa sería una situación con
desempleo estructural porque sus
habilidades no coinciden con los
trabajos con el tiempo tendrían que
aprender
relacionadas con los coches pero si lo
piensan la economía siempre está
cambiando hoy en día por ejemplo la
tecnología está en constante evolución
la economía tiene nuevas necesidades
continuamente y siempre habrá un
desajuste entre las habilidades que la
gente posee en este momento y las
habilidades que los empleadores
requieren esto también puede
relacionarse con donde se encuentra la
gente tal vez la gente no está en el
lugar donde están los puestos de trabajo
o al contrario pasemos al desempleo
friccional este surge de la idea de que
existen algunas fricciones cuando
buscamos trabajo tenemos que enviar un
currículum y acudir a entrevistas no
todos pasan directamente de un trabajo
al otro eso sería ideal pero muchas
veces se gradúan de la universidad y
tienen que salir a buscar trabajo
mientras que los empleadores tienen que
buscar cómo cubrir las vacantes y este
es simplemente un estado natural de las
cosas con el tiempo si la tecnología
mejora y se encuentran mejores maneras
de hacer coincidir la búsqueda con el
trabajo el desempleo friccional podría
disminuir aunque es casi imposible que
desaparezca
siempre habrá personas en el mercado
laboral buscando trabajo activamente que
poseen las habilidades requeridas para
un trabajo por lo que no se contabilizan
en el desempleo estructural pero que aún
no encuentran ese trabajo vamos a
terminar aquí espero que esto les ayude
a entender que con frecuencia la tasa de
desempleo que vemos puede estar
comparada con la tasa natural de
desempleo y el desempleo cíclico y que
la tasa natural de desempleo se compone
de desempleo estructural y desempleo
friccional los cuales pueden ser estados
naturales del mercado laboral nos vemos
en el siguiente vídeo